it's a rare thing when a great beauty
becomes a great actress if you don't
think our next presenter is a great
actress look at again her award-winning
performance and to women and if you
don't think she's a great beauty take a
look at the greatest pizza maker in the
world mr. feel around
Thank You mr. Sinatra I meant every one
of us how come we never worked it up
well we we did don't you remember in
Spain when we did that picture of the
pride and the passion what wasn't that
you well I was not a heavier than
another of course not mega
it is my privilege to present the Oscar
for the best performance by an actor
those nominated are Burt Lancaster in
Birdman of Alcatraz Jack Lemmon in days
or wine and roses Michelle Yeoh
Mastriani in divorce italian-style Peter
O'Toole in Lawrence of Arabia Gregory
Peck in To Kill a Mockingbird la most of
its armor
gambit while the winner is Gregory Peck
you
thank you hello Academy members thank
you hardly haven't Akula Robert Mulligan
Russ Harlan all of my good friends and
associates at the studio Thank You
members of the press who cover the local
scene critics columnist across the
country who approved in my work and said
so and I want to thank my family my good
close friends who lent me inspiration a
moral support and affection thank you
very much
you